Barry believes in aliens it's cuz he's
seen them yeah you've seen aliens you
said that the last time you were here
yeah I told you I see him every day
every day I spoke to him before I got
here
they say they don't speak out loud
uh-huh kind of spoke to them today yes
what are they are they aware this show
yeah there were a how they are they are
yeah they like you how they do they love
you I say I don't know if I believe you
all of us they really are aware of me
now they now he doesn't know if he
believes it why are you not worthy of a
recognition you know and everyone
assumes that aliens are so much smarter
than us they are so when you guys wrote
this song you know we make good pets you
were talking about if these aliens came
and visited us and we suddenly became a
planet of pets
yeah and that was written before I saw
them oh really yeah yeah this is a very
profound song yes we make because we
make good pets think about if we had
there was a species of something more
intelligent than us we'd be their pet do
you feel when these aliens visit you
they treat you like a pet well I checked
it out man okay it's like going to
college eventually you're gonna be as
smart as your professor but your
professor teaches you and I think that's
the way it goes I think that we're being
nurtured and raised and we're we're you
know you know loved yeah conditions you
know and you know what I mean but I
don't ever think my cat is gonna be as
smart as me right eventually eventually
it will Rahm you're not that smart
alright never mind this I want to I want
to I want to hear that this is a perfect
segue for the song and it's one of my
favorite songs that you do well yeah it
is a great song you know that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Magers
[Music]
and now
like shoes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
take over
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
very nice very nice boys good job